imagine the world as a high resolution
place
in your eyes looking at it from a low
resolution perspective
in such a world the tools that we have
at our disposal
to make sense of it are quite limited
humanity has invested a lot of resources
in the
development of science and technology
that can reduce our fallibility and
increase our comprehension of this
complex reality
yet we still feel so lost i have brooded
over this idea a lot
and i have come to the following
conclusion in the grand scheme of things
what happens in the world
is relatively out of our control we
follow the news
we try to participate in democratic
processes we try to be active members of
society
but still the monumental change is
required to
affect certain aspects of the world that
need fixing
render the effect of our participation
quite minuscule
sometimes even meaningless so what role
do we actually play in the world
on a more personal level how do we
properly use our own mental and physical
apparatus
to alleviate the effect of complexity on
our thinking and decision making
processes
how hard do we try to understand
ourselves in order to
improve the interplay between us and the
world around us
how hard do we try to understand
ourselves in order to
offer the chance to ourselves to improve
the resolution of our perspective
i think not hard enough and it all
starts with a notion of personality
jordan peterson has stated that a
personality is an evolved solution to
the problem of an overly complex world
he said that because personality shapes
our perception
and defines the way one looks at the
world we're social creatures
we're not alone coexistence is at the
core of our social function
we are in a sense a dynamic amalgam of
different personalities and
in order to co-exist we should first
understand our personalities
and then find a way to bridge
personality differences with one another
and the most appropriate tool we can
currently use for this endeavor
is the big five personality traits model
the big five is the most widely accepted
theory of personality today
it has been cited in thousands of papers
and it is acknowledged by most
psychologists out there
the reason is quite straightforward it
offers a quite
accurate description of the individual
by narrowing down his or her focus
to five important traits and its trait
is subdivided into two more
also the assessment of its trait is not
binary
i.e introvert or extrovert but rather
its personality trait
occupies a spectrum this offers a more
holistic understanding of one's
personality
and allows the individual to have a more
nuanced view into his
or her inner world the big five is
composed of the traits
extraversion neuroticism agreeableness
conscientiousness and openness to
experience this might not sound like a
lot but
trust me if you consider how randomly
situated people
are across the spectrum of its trait you
end up with a dynamic assemblage
of different groups that is difficult to
assess and organize
that's a consequence of our
unpredictable environments its
personality is affected by
genetic and environmental factors and
this renders the potentiality of a
rather
homogenous set of personalities within a
social group
quite difficult that's why models like
the big 5 are so useful
by evaluating our personality traits we
can become more aware of who we are and
also seek out environments where
we can put these traits into use we can
match with people who are similar to us
and can be great potential partners
but also cooperate with people who can
be different and by
capitalizing on diversity can help us
solve
all sorts of problems the power of the
big five
simply cannot be ignored the model can
help us conceptualize the world around
us better
discover objective truths that are of
pragmatic
utility and allow humanity to move
forward
in a less confused fashion
every aspect of the big five breaks down
into two categories
for extra version the two categories are
assertiveness and enthusiasm
assertiveness is a combination of
healthy confidence and
the ability to stand up for yourself and
your rights without however
disrespecting the rights of others
when you are assertive you are direct
and honest with people
you don't expect others to read your
mind about what you want
if something is bothering you you speak
up if you want or need something
you ask in simple words assertiveness is
a gentle demonstration of confident
characteristics
enthusiasm is closely related to comfort
and especially comfort in one's skin
enthusiastic people are more open and
they bring more energy to an interaction
they make friends easily reveal a lot
about themselves
and show their feelings extraversion is
essentially the positive emotion
dimension
what this means is that by being more
extroverted
you increase the probability of putting
yourself out there in the world
humans are explorers and extraversion
abets our need to dive into unfamiliar
territories
this can include more risk but also more
opportunity
the upside is that people high in
extraversion tend to form
more relationships and by doing so they
increase their social network and also
the probability of randomness and
forcing experiences upon them
both of which can prove beneficial in
succeeding in personal
and professional endeavors the downside
is that more exposure means
more vulnerability and this requires a
lot of resilience and the ability to
confront different people and views
it also means that the ego can be
inflated and that can affect their mood
behavior humility and proactivity
neuroticism can be broken down into
withdrawal and volatility
both facets of neuroticism are related
to negative emotion
and how the individual deals with it in
the case of withdrawal
the individual will internalize negative
emotion this describes people who are
anxious
depressed worry about things get easily
discouraged
become overwhelmed by events and in
general keep their psychological pain
inside them
in the case of volatility the individual
will externalize negative emotion
this describes people who are touchy
easily offended easily irritated
and demonstrate externally their
response to negative emotion
neuroticism is something very common
among humans it's like a reaction
mechanism by the body
that signals a bad situation experienced
by the individual
it's like anxiety you feel anxiety so
that you don't have to feel pain
anxiety prepares you for things that can
hurt you it is not pleasant
but it is an evolution mechanism and
because we haven't really adapted
efficiently to modern society
neuroticism is quite prevalent amongst
us to put it in different words
negative emotion determines how prone
you are to reacting negatively to the
obstacles in your path
the more you react the easier it is to
fall into depression
because you suppress your positive
emotion system and you remain stale
there is a clear indication here that
the human mind and body
are designed in a way that demands
movement the more static we become
the more negative emotion we produce
positive emotion releases dopamine which
is analgesic
meaning that it alleviates pain so what
do you do in order to reduce
neuroticism you're really high in trait
neuroticism you know so you're prone to
anxiety and
and negative emotion like you can
stabilize yourself through exposure
right so don't avoid things you're
afraid of
if especially i should be more specific
about that
if you're on a path to somewhere we've
delineated the path
and things emerged that you're afraid of
that if you avoided would compromise
your journey forward
don't avoid them break them into pieces
learn how to
in learn how to confront them and that
will strengthen you and it'll it'll
strengthen your character and it'll
lower your levels of neuroticism
but you're you're never in all
likelihood going to go from
98th percentile of neuroticism to like
second percentile
you could but you'd have to do nothing
but that your entire life and even then
it might not work so maybe if you
meditated
carefully in a tibetan retreat and you
didn't have to worry about anything else
you could
shift yourself two or three standard
deviations but
the the the amount of effort is
proportional to the movement right
so when you want to encourage
development in people
you have to find a small and performable
step forward
that constitutes improvement and point
them to that direction
this is groundbreaking and it showcases
two things
number one how prone our mind and
behavior are
to habit building and number two how
this can also be applied to a societal
scale
and affect general behavioral patterns
within the population
by choosing tangible goals that are not
extremely ambitious
you indicate to your anxiety systems
that you're more competent
then the thing is dangerous gradually
you get accustomed to the new
environment and
assuage the effect of neuroticism in
your life
in the social arena we need to form
opinions tackle problems
forge alliances and attempt to co-exist
the level of cooperation we can
establish is predicated upon how
agreeable or disagreeable we are as
people
this personality trait is called
agreeableness and it is composed of
compassion
and politeness compassion refers to how
sensitive we are to others needs and
feelings
compassionate people are more empathetic
invest in others
have a soft side and are easier to get
along with
politeness refers to how much we respect
authority
and reflects how prone we are to conform
to social norms
high agreeableness distinguishes people
who are caring
it is like the maternal aspect of their
personality
but there is an upside and a downside to
that too much agreeableness can render
one extremely dependent on others
unable to establish autonomy on their
own and also incapable of forming their
own views
this can also be defined as childlike
dependent characteristics extended into
adulthood
too much disagreeableness is associated
with
low-level integration of various
information necessary for both
understanding
and sharing the emotional world of
others disagreeableness is closely
related to antagonism
and the propensity of the individual to
demonstrate aggressive behavior
whenever their sense of justice is
provoked agreeableness is tricky
most relationships are like a trading
game the question is how much should you
care for others
and how much for yourself this
definitely depends on the occasion but
a rule of thumb to follow is that in
every human relationship
reciprocity should be the fundamental
rule of the game
the oxford dictionary defines
conscientiousness as the quality of
wishing to do one's work
or duty well and thoroughly a
conscientious person is a careful and
diligent person
the subdivisions of conscientiousness
are industriousness
and orderliness industries is someone
who is effective and efficacious
they carry out their plans follow a
well-organized schedule
meet deadlines finish what they start
and know what they're doing
orderliness refers to people who like to
have their personal space in order
they are tidy avoid clutter follow
routines and rituals and are
bothered by disorder conscientious
people value duty
diligence and focus it is a trait that
can predict success in the workplace but
the weird thing about conscientiousness
is that it is very difficult to measure
apart from self-report tests there is no
real good model that can predict or
measure the level of conscientiousness
in a person
and that's probably because
conscientiousness emerges from other
functions
the actual origin of the word is
controlled by conscience
governed by the known rules of right and
wrong so
there is a clear correlation between
conscientiousness and morality
moral people tend to follow rules and
order in order to
allow morality to flourish through those
rules but even morality itself is a
debatable topic within society
there is also a connection between
orderliness and disgust
and industriousness and guilt the more
sensitive someone is to disgust
the more he or she will take care of the
aesthetics and the cleanliness of their
surroundings
with regards to industriousness it could
be that industrious people
work a lot because they feel guilty
guilty because
if they don't work they don't offer to
the community
as you can imagine excess orderliness
can lead to certain pathologies
there is always a dark side to every
trait
openness to experience reflects the
ability to chase new experiences and
engage in creative pursuits people low
in openness tend to prefer their comfort
zone and safe spaces
whereas people high in openness tend to
question the boundaries of conventional
knowledge and seek innovation
openness to experience is subdivided
mainly to openness and intellect but
it can also involve six dimensions
including active imagination
aesthetic sensitivity attentiveness to
inner feelings
preference for variety and intellectual
curiosity
the first five dimensions are connected
to creativity and introspection
people who score high in these
dimensions tend to enjoy abstract
thinking challenging problems and are
intellectually curious with regards to
intellect we need to mention that
intellect is not measuring intelligence
or iq dr todd grande
explains it perfectly in this video when
we look at the
personality trait of openness to
experience in general we know that it
does have a positive correlation
even though it's relatively weak with
intelligence
and a lot of that correlation we see
loaded here on this intellect facet
as opposed to the other facets of
openness to experience
so intellect doesn't measure
intelligence
it measures a tendency to be interested
in learning new things and be challenged
it has an association with intelligence
an individual who scores low on
intellect tends to like to deal with
people interact with people as opposed
to ideas
and usually they don't appreciate
philosophy
and theory as much as they do concrete
thinking
they tend to view intellectual
activities as a poor use of time
so the intellect facet really deals with
a
intellectual style as opposed to
an intellectual ability as far as
intelligence is concerned
according to wikipedia openness to
experiences
moderately associated with crystallized
intelligence crystallized intelligence
refers to
cognitive functions associated with
previously acquired knowledge and
long-term store that is the ability to
use learned knowledge and
experience different experiences offer
different ways to view different
problems
and that can have a huge impact on the
intellectual development
of the individual
life is balance the whole world is built
on balance
balance is key in establishing systems
of beneficial order both within
ourselves and within society as a whole
disrupting balance may cause a person or
social group to go astray
and lose themselves in chimeras and
delusions
sometimes we might need to disrupt
balance when we see that the current
systems are not favoring the common good
but
eventually we will have to re-establish
it understanding our personalities is
key for this process
becoming aware of who we are and how
different personality traits are
favoring or jeopardizing our lives and
the lives of others
is instrumental in our self-development
and coexistence with others
a person who knows himself has nothing
to fear because
he knows which demons to fight a person
who doesn't know himself
will most probably fight the wrong
demons
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like
subscribe turn on notifications and
comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon editor now
you